foreign
Ville what's up Jackie
oh not much just child problems
uh if you got child problems I feel bad
for you son I got 99 okay so what's up
tell me what's going on
okay so my youngest is going to be 13 in
about a month okay
um I got a 12 year old same let's figure
this out awesome
I no longer know what to do or how to
handle situations with him okay
um
right now he is failing almost every
class okay fighting with every teacher
his school's fed up with him
um they're threatening to keep him in
the principal's office for the rest of
the year and do all of his classes
except PE in the principal's office okay
um he won't do chores at home and I
don't ask a lot you know keep his room
clean straighten up his bathroom into
the dishwasher I mean it's not a lot
um
I tried taking Privileges and I try
giving Privileges and bribery and
everything and I'm just I'm at a loss
oh man I'm sorry ah jeez I'm sorry
um
this sounds like a boy that doesn't feel
safe why wouldn't he feel safe
um I'm
was a single mom his father actually
passed away about three years ago and he
never really had anything to do with him
um he kept it hidden from his family and
they just recently came into his life
about three or four years ago
so there's that and then you know young
dumb mom you know bounced around so he's
you know
had a
really two different stable people in
his life but
um
you say bounce around like just
different boyfriends different
boyfriends or different marriages yeah
uh only one marriage
um recently got divorced it was just a
bad situation
um what does that mean was it was there
abuse in the home no I mean his my
mother-in-law was
kind of a terror
um she wouldn't let him do you know
stuff on his own and would get no you
know mad like if he spilled milk corn
cereal you know dumb stuff
it's just a lot so I finally got out of
that situation and I moved in with um my
parents for a little while
and then you know young and dumb again
got you know went straight into another
relationship and I've been living with
him for about three years but he's never
had any children so he doesn't know how
to handle him and I feel like I'm
constantly man in the middle
between the two of them and you know
my boyfriend's like telling this I'm
like why don't you just tell him
so I don't know what to do
and underneath all of this is a little
kid
right
hiding in a teenage
hiding in a teenage body
is a little kid saying what was so wrong
with me the dead left
why does God hate me so much that Daddy
died
and who the hell is this guy think he is
talking to my mom like that talking to
me like that
who is this other Grandma trying to tell
me that I'm a bad kid for spilling milk
like and all of a sudden that little 12
year old boy
his body explodes from the inside out
and so when you describe those things I
don't see a bad kid at all I see a kid
screaming somebody please tell me I'm
okay
I know and I'm I'm trying to get him to
open up
he has no way he's gonna open up
no way I wouldn't
not after some third or fourth
radioactive alpha male in my house
trying to go to war with me as a 12 year
old
I'm not gonna open up in that
environment in a way
and the last time I opened up to an
elderly person she got mad at me for
spilling cornflakes
and so he sits on it he has learned I'm
gonna sit on this the only problem is he
doesn't have the strength and fortitude
or access to alcohol to do it
like most men do or he doesn't have a
graduate degree from law school to go
hide in his office for the next 40 years
and so he just explodes
he is not a bad kid
no he's not unfortunately he's too smart
for his own good
the teachers are constantly like he
spurts around the rules by doing this
this and this but he's not
breaking the rules
and I constantly tell him I'm like you
know listen Jackie the words you just
said I constantly tell them I don't care
I don't care what you tell him no words
will get through to this 12 year old
little boy zero words
he has learned to respond to two things
power
and connection
do you know what a dream it would be for
him to be able to do his work by himself
in a non-threatening environment in the
principal's office where adults are nice
to him
that would be the greatest gift to his
sweet little brain and his sweet little
body peace
adults who are actually kind to him
who hold him accountable and challenge
him academically but love him because he
doesn't have that
he's got a mom who is rattled From the
Inside Out probably has been for a long
time and I'm not blaming you it just
isn't is
he's gotta come on it doesn't help that
I have
dealt with depression on and off and I'm
finally getting myself healthy so I'm
you know finally getting the strength to
deal with everything good good good good
you can he can only be as well as you
are
and I know that's a scary proposition
for you
um would it benefit Ed
trying to
get him into that but he's like let's go
there and I'll just stare at him so I'm
like I don't know if that's that's worth
the fight to try to
he needs a couple of men in his life
that he can actually trust and aren't
gonna harp on him all the time about it
pull his pants up and fix his belt and
is that what you're wearing turn your
shirt around he needs a couple of guys
in his life they'll take him fishing and
laugh with him on my my um
dad was a stepdad but he you know tries
to take him out constantly and my
boyfriend like wants to go out and do
four-wheeling and paintballing and all
that stuff with him but then he gets mad
because he's not listening to him so
yeah he I mean and it sounds like I'm
saying it's a free-for-all absolutely
not he needs to experience
accountability he needs to experience
choices but he also needs to experience
autonomy and he needs to experience more
than anything a safe environment and
he's never had that
and you know this and I'm not saying
this to I'm saying this to challenge you
not to kick you while you're down okay
no I understand this is all of the
recipes for the making of a disaster
down the road
this is a brilliant
unsafe
boy about to become a brilliant unsafe
man
and that's a danger
right
and so it sounds like what he needs is a
good butt kicking nope
what he needs is to feel safe and secure
for the first time in his life
ever
this is going to sound bananas but I
would start with
you've heard me say this a million times
on the show when's the last time you
just took him out and listened to him
how'd things going I'm not trying to
coach you or teach you or tell you like
how's it going that's a dangerous
question because
um for the last two years my work's been
working six days a week 10 hour days so
okay I'm out of the house a lot okay
part of you getting well might be
thinking I've got to get a different job
part of you getting well might be this
like romantic relationship I'm in that
I'm in the Band-Aid over the last one
which Band-Aids over the last one which
Band-Aids over a lifetime of fill in the
blank
those aren't serving me well
and when I'm not when you don't feel
safe and by the way Jackie you don't
feel safe either I can hear it on you
you feel one one uh
one tiny like
spider's web you're hanging on by
is that true
yeah a little bit
I think part of it's just
I'm at the point where I'm like is he
going to get frustrated enough that you
know he's gonna want to kick us out
who of the home
why are you trying to please him
why
because he's the first person that's
actually made me feel like I have a life
and I'm worth living then he shouldn't
be making you feel like you got to
perform for him or he or you're you're
off the stage
and he might not be saying those words
but that might be what you're projecting
on to him and that's not fair if you're
doing that to him
kind of keeps bottle stuff bottled up
bottled up and you know has a hard time
explaining I know but you know women and
children are
Exquisite at absorbing that sort of
tension you know why because they have
to to keep alive
and so when he's all bottled up you feel
it and you can nuzzle up to him and be
romantic and make the meal that you can
do all those things bring home the
paycheck that he wants you can do that
but your body knows we're not safe
all right you know especially knows that
the finest tuned radar in your home is
that sweet little 13 year old boy
not one thing you've described to me is
out of character for that little boy
I'm so heartbroken for him I can hardly
even stand it because I gotta I got a
boy just like him
the difference is announce again I'm not
perfect parent by a long shot
my kid can be goofy he can be a 12 year
old he could be a 13 year old he can do
all all the middle school boy things
but that boy knows he's safe and that
boy knows he is loved
all right
and that's where we're going to start
with him
very like quick out of the gate if you
said give me three things to do right
now
I would say you have to figure out a
work schedule where you go to
you leave in the morning early or you go
in the evening and you take him on a
date once a week
without fail twice a week if you can
no boyfriend no whatever y'all go
together
I can do that I get 4 30 in the
afternoon so awesome and once a week he
gets to pick the restaurant once a week
you get to pick it
and it might mean you can't afford it
and you're gonna have to forego
something cool for you I don't want Taco
Bell
well I mean that's pretty I've taken my
son there
um sometimes he picks that place just to
torture me but that is what it is and
then I get Dorito tacos and everything's
better for about eight minutes well I'm
on a carnivore diet so I'll probably
have to fast while he's eating it no but
don't no no no don't do that eat
forget the con what's like why do the
car why now why now
because it's helping my migraines and my
depression and all that good stuff all
right or whatever really good reason
okay
Taco Bell will not help those three
things
um right I'll just eat the beef he gets
to pick
and here's what we're gonna do
we are not going to lecture him whenever
you feel yourself reaching up to give
him advice you're gonna stop
you're gonna listen
you're going to ask him questions like
what scares you
what are you missing I'm gonna send you
all the questions for humans cards you
can use with him okay
you can take them and this is going to
be your date it's gonna be your game and
then if he has another game he wants to
play cool if he wants to get a puzzle
and just not talk cool
the second thing we're gonna do every
single morning and every single evening
before bed you are gonna hug him to your
chest
for 30 seconds and he doesn't get a vote
but he kind of does
okay and you're not gonna say mama needs
a hug because he already feels like he
has to take care of you and he can't
carry that
all right you're going to say mom really
wants to hug her the most important man
in her life
will you give Mom the opportunity to hug
the man that she loves more than any
other man on the planet
that's what we're gonna say every single
day
and then he's gonna go
and you'll say
I want to hug the most important man of
the planet
the third thing is you have to be on the
lookout for
male influences in his life that aren't
just going to take a paintball and show
them how to drink beer and how to whip
ass and be a man not that
who are going to see him and love him
and provide a good model for what this
what being a man looks like and that's
doing hard stuff
and that's being honest and that's being
open and that's being vulnerable and
that's feeling things and going and
doing hard crap anyway
and if that's not your boyfriend get out
get out
thank you
would it be beneficial to have my father
try to take him out once a week too if
you think that's a safe good person
he's amazing that would be incredible
and now this little boy is going to
start getting the thing he needs more
than anything else which is adults who
love him who not don't tell him who show
him through their most precious resource
their time
he's gonna get something he desperately
needs which is to be fully seen and have
be at be rest assured I still love you
awesome okay and did you by the way you
were playing a 10-year game here what
we're doing right now we are hoping that
that 25 year old kid
who's now a 25 year old man
with all of the rights and privileges of
grown men
in our society we're hoping that guy
looks back and thinks man my mom really
had a rough go of it the first decade of
my life and that that brave incredible
woman turns it around
man I was really blessed to have my
grandpa in my life
that guy walked alongside me and he was
met with me every week forever drove me
crazy and I'm missing my crazy
okay well luckily we're a pretty young
family so he'll have him for a while
cool but but you're but all that to say
is this isn't going to get better in
four months
okay the last thing I'll say is this is
number four and then I'm Gonna Let You
Go
I would come up with some sort of set of
family values that he gets to speak into
thank you
and that might be on your third or
fourth or fifth or sixth date that
you'll have in a row
you could tell them hey I've been
wondering who I'm gonna be who I want to
be who you want to be and not just what
job we're going to do but who are we
going to be
would you make a list with me let's do a
project together
and this will be a project that says
we're going to talk to people with
respect and dignity we we get our work
done on time we show up on time that's
just who we are where people who treat
other people right and we treat them
right by if they give us an assignment
we just get it done
and that way when he chooses to not do
his homework you've got something back
to say Hey you chose this consequence
too because you know who we are we all
agreed on it
and he gets to hold you accountable mom
when you yell and scream or kick or
throw something he gets to say
that's not who we are we said we were
going to be this
and then you have to pay him 20 bucks
that's the fine
film chair is it fair but here's what
we're doing the the nerd word is
autonomy
we're giving him some tiny feeling that
he has some bit of control in his life
and up to this point he's had none
no control he has been the whim of
adults who are doing acting like
children running around doing Child
Things in adult bodies and he's
terrified and now he's God man now that
sweet little boy has a chance to just do
his homework in peace in the principal's
office and principles can be tough but
man they love
smart good kids
in those school secretaries in the
principal's office and those School
administrators
they would be nice to him finally
when your kids everybody when your kids
are
acting out
let your first question not be what's
wrong with my kid
let your first question be why doesn't
my kid feel safe
start there
solve for safety